for generations a code of conduct has
governed the nation's art museums and
one rule range supreme you don't sell
pieces from your collection to pay the
bills but now with doors closed and
revenue drying up museums of all kinds
are in desperate straits and that
time-honored restriction is getting a
more artful interpretation all in an
effort to help these institutions
survive christina Ruffini has the story
it's a coveted privilege of museum
curators having a private audience with
world-class works of art but lately the
many many silent galleries around the
country don't feel magical so much as
depressing I think this moment is thrown
into relief the fact that museums are
really deeply dialogic and really deeply
community-based and absent people there
is no conversation
Christopher Bedford directs the
Baltimore Museum of Art does it bum you
out to come in here and see it
completely empty yes yes
now instead of conversing about culture
many are talking survival and wondering
aloud if they should reconsider one of
their most sacred rules do not touch the
art do sessioning yes what is that
that's all code word why is it so
secretive that's our code word for
selling art for decades most museums
have followed a strict and some might
say stringent set of guidelines they're
not supposed to solve financial problems
by plucking paintings off the wall sales
are only allowed if proceeds enhanced
the larger collection like when the BMA
sold several pieces from its archive to
acquire more works by women and artists
of color
you sold art to buy more art that's
exactly correct but you can't sell art
yes you do pretty much anything else so
that is the big no-no fast violators
have been ostracized and even picketed
like in 2018 when the berkshire museum
raised funds by sending dozens of pieces
and to norman rockwell's to auction but
the pandemic has changed everyone's
perspective and forced a
reinterpretation of the DIA sessioning
rule what we're trying to achieve is to
provide our member organizations with a
little bit more from financial
flexibility Brad Benjamin is
president of the association of art
museum directors for the next two years
it says it will not punish members that
use art sales to pay for quote the care
of the collection what that means is up
to the institution's themselves we've
never done this before but this is a
circumstance we've never faced before
so why does it matter if museums want to
sell their art well because the museum
exists in perpetuity and the idea is
that you don't benefit today's visitors
at the expense of tomorrow's and you
don't benefit tomorrow's visitors at the
expense of today
Nina Del Rio vice chairman at Sotheby's
auction house has handled many
high-profile dia sessions this is a
decision that has been you know within
committee a long time coming she says
having more flexibility and control over
their assets might be key to many
museums survival but don't expect a fire
sale I've not seen anybody so far say oh
my god we have to sell everything you
know life is going to be over if we
don't I've seen quite the opposite
the stewards of these institutions doing
the thoughtful hard and good work to
demonstrate that they're making you know
decisions that that are the right ones
for their particular institution and
even though he doesn't think the BMA
will need to take advantage of the rule
change bedford says he supports it in
the abstract
what is more sacred a set of values that
we have collectively determined or the
vitality relevance and core mission and
vision of institutions to serve their
publics I think this moment is telling
us exactly which is more important which
is serving our publics being vital being
relevant keeping our doors open because
without its patrons even the best museum
is really just a vault for CBS this
morning Saturday
Christina Ruffini Baltimore